well you may recall that Harry and Megan
the favorite friends of this show spent
years trashing the Royals as a bunch of
cruel privileged races trapped in a
terrible prison of an institution so
imagine our surprise when a spokesperson
for the couple confirmed via People
magazine that Princess Lily bet Diner
had been christened
why would they use a title for their
children that represents an institution
they loathe so much well joining me now
to discuss what this is authoring
historian Tessa Dunlop royalties of the
Daily Mirror Russell Myers and Michael
Cole's remainder because of course he
was the BBC's voice of royalty for two
decades as he reminded us uh all right
Russell miles I don't get this no
because I was sure that they kept
telling the world how ghastly the
monarchy is it's a prison cam all the
Royals want to get away from it but they
can't because they're trapped in the
world of titles and privilege and now
they want to give their kids the titles
of prince and princess even though they
don't live anywhere near the royal
family they don't do any duties they
have nothing to deserve it they live in
a mansion in Montecito in California and
use their their own royal title to make
loads of money which may be declared to
why they want their kids to have them
yeah if it were you pretty much summed
it up for a lot of people they're seeing
this hypocrisy being played out it's
like a soap opera isn't it that uh
something out of an EastEnders script
and uh Harry and Megan have made an
awful lot of money and an awful lot of
noise over the last couple of years by
say telling everybody how awful the
monarchy is and the monarchy that they
left behind indeed Harry and Megan
wanted a half in half out model the
queen said that they couldn't and so
yeah it's very very surprising that they
should uh they should want this poor you
so surprised I would say Tessa Dunlop
rank hypocrisy yet again
first time on the show agreeing with you
you wait he'll turn the screws in a
minute I would like to suggest that
Harry and Megan it's a bit like
criticizing the police force I often
criticize the Met police my uncle was a
commissioner in the Met police doesn't
mean that I don't believe in having a
police force you can criticize the
monarchy and say here are the fault
lines and do it clums why would they
want why would they want to inflict on
their children Royal titles that make
them part of the royal family worldwide
and expose them to the misery and pain
and Trauma which Harry tells us he
suffers on an hourly basis normally for
large checks by the way because isn't it
very clear they've left the rigid
institution yes
institution and they're going and
they've got monarchy light Atlantic
style that's what they've done why do
they want the titles I understand
what do you understand
well a couple of reasons one is yeah
there's cachet
pricelessness that's cash yeah
and cash oh come on because we all know
Harry and Megan as Harry and Megan would
be making a lot less money if they
weren't the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
which goes on every statement they ever
met I just want to share something with
Michael and Russell and this is an
epiphany I had today when thinking about
peers I do occasionally think about you
off screen
I've come to the conclusion that
although you sit there night after night
professing to be a monarchist you're not
deep down I am no because the whole
point is with the system of hereditary
monarchy you can't choose the loons and
losers that get born with the right to
people no you can't okay
it's all very odd it's pick and mix
isn't it we want the traffic yes we want
them we don't want the juicy we don't
want the hard work it's this is all very
very odd because legally they became
Archie and lillybet because became
prince and princess at the moment Her
Majesty the queen died on the 8th of
September and King Charles took over
because by the latter's patent uh drawn
by King George V in 1917 grandchildren
of a reigning monarch become
automatically Prince and this is what
Meghan Markle was struggling to remember
in her Oprah one of them when she
claimed the only reason she hadn't been
already made of Prince was because of
his skin color it turned out she just
didn't understand okay no I'm asking
Michael because he knows about these
things of course about how the system
actually works there was no racism no
none at all and that was actually quite
shameful what was said at that time I
must remember what she said this is what
she told 50 million people around the
world what did I do recall it and regret
it's worth reminding the idea of the
first
member of color in this family not being
titled in the same way
that other grandchildren would be it's
not their right to take it away
it was a complete hang on Tessa it was a
complete lie appalling ignorance
appalling ignorance and also used in a
very very nasty way yeah attack people
who couldn't answer back yes and Brian
them a bunch of races when they were
racism is a is a terrible accusation to
make because it's easy to make well once
thrown
Tessa you'll see them why you've just
heard a lion but I think that the key we
need to pick up on there is the word
ignorance Michael I steamed former BBC
journalist 80 years he's been walking on
this planet absorbing ideas of
hereditary monarchy in the British
constitution Megan you're not 80. on
Monday I was 80. are you serious I'm
sorry Michael Cole you look unbelievable
crazy really yes I was well happy
birthday thank you very much
congratulations on being uh
correspondence uh okay Russell let's
bring this back to the thing the ongoing
thing is are they going to come to the
the coronation they threw their little
licks Bittle Omid scoby uh he said that
apparently they invited all the Royals
to uh lillibet's um christening but they
all declined to come as if they're all
going to get on a plane and fly to
California to embrace the people who've
been trashing them for the last three
years but it looks like from The Jungle
drums they have been invited yeah yeah
to the coronation right now they're
holding it out to make get all about
them make it a big drama so do you think
they're actually going to come uh I do
now yeah I think because it's their
currency isn't it they've made an awful
lot of money and again this uh it's
they're attacked by by having that
Association right the royal family you
mentioned
um the the favored journalists that they
were briefing in the in the first
instance that they weren't going to have
titles and now there's another screech
in U-turn we already had one of the
u-turns about the racism element within
the royal family that Prince William was
forced to deny Michael you want a drunk
person this is another example
is his majesty the King has played a
Blinder in all this because he led it
made it let it be known from the very
outset that they were welcome to come
Megan and Harry to the coronation
putting the ball firmly in their court
if they decline it will make them look
small-minded Petty mean-minded and if
they accept
they will make them look open the door
to hypocrisy
in the tenth row right behind prince
Andrew so when the world's cameras get
beamed on them all they see is their
little heads bearing around them
the King has spoken about unity and
togetherness so and I don't think you
would be as cherlish as to not invite
them I actually think you shouldn't have
invited why would you invite a couple of
rap bags you've been attacking every
member of your family because if I'm
just saying what I would have done if
that was people in my family I wouldn't
want them anywhere my coronation which
by the way can only be a matter of time
yeah but do you make the point there all
you have to do is one of your Offspring
marry into the royal family and hey
Presto the Morgans get a little tingy
monarchy that is how unbelievably mad
the system of predatory Monarch is we
all get fat chewing the fat of this
story but the problem you have peers is
you like the system when it works but
you don't like it when it doesn't no no
no Harry is an example no no you
completely misrepresent what I think
about the molecule my mother camped on
the mouth of both Diana and Fergie's
weddings right we grew up we had we run
a country Pub in East Sussex well I
remember this 1977 Silver Jubilee the
street parties and everything it was
fantastic so I grew up when it's working
hang on oh it wasn't working even then
right there's always been chaos and
Carnage in the royal family you know
when I was a newspaper editor barely a
week went by without some new Scandal
that's not the point the distinction
with these two is they have openly
attacked the institution of the monarchy
Diana didn't do that Fergie didn't do
that they have unloaded on the
institution being a prison camp that no
one can escape from why then would they
call their kids prince and princess I
was 10 at the last coronation you
haven't asked me to guess peers but I'm
going to guess what will happen
May the 6th is Archie's birthday yeah I
rather fancy that she will stay behind
and have a birthday party in California
and he will come particularly as three
days later he's due to be the star
witness in a very contentious case
that's going to be opened against mirror
group newspapers and he's going to go
into the witness box yeah that is going
to come after the Lord mayor show we
know what happens after the coronation
yeah we've got a court case no Harry as
we know is very concerned about privacy
uh on that bombshell on that bombshell
we'll leave it but yes it's going to be
an interesting month uh lovely to see
you Michael love to see you great to see
you pleasure thank you all very much